はぁっはぁっはぁっあねっ
見ての通りね僕のベッド汚いんですよで砲弾か先寝れないしベッドっ
もう嫌だねぇなんか嫌なんですよ
まあねまあ普通のペットについてともうちょっと出れないって事がわかったのでまあ
自分で新型のベッドを作ろうと思います今日は
みんなもすぐ作れると思うんですけど何て言うんだろうね
なんていうんだろ絶えずコレットが部テープでクモの巣を作りません
くまってみては取るとりゃーネットのあのアピア美な感じですごい込めやすいんですよ
知らないですけど
ハンモックといいじゃないんですけどまぁ規模の素敵な感じで新しいこの睡眠ライフを
ね
部活の住みたいわ
なんですよ私を見てたらわかるんだよという切れ間から新しい別を作りますよ
それは寝不足でやる気ないんですけど
頑張って作っていこうと思いますよし
[音楽]
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
4日
4を
をの
ん
ぜひ他全4に
いやね痩せそうだなぁ
持っています
[音楽]
持っていた
ん
4の
6本
[音楽]
ブーッ
乱読新しい寝床ができたわけなんですけども
早速見てみようと思います
こんなけですこんなに強気なの全然でれると思うんですよ
ぜひねぜひ皆さんも家なんか美馬のふと胸にくいなぁと思ったら是非
クモの巣作って寝ることを説明しますじゃあおやすみなさい
大丈夫大丈夫です
大丈夫
俺は大丈夫
[音楽]
ん
e 7